[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to once again
be discussing events that transpired in
the harry potter universe after the
books and films ended this is the second
part in this series so if you're wanting
to learn about 10 more characters in
addition to the 10 featured in this
video then i'll leave a link in the
pinned comment as i mentioned last time
with the latest fantastic beast film on
the way the secrets of dumbledore we can
expect to learn even more information
about the wizarding world before harry
ron and hermione embarked on her journey
at hogwarts however what i want to hone
in on today are the events that happened
afterwards let's find out number one
umbridge umbridge is arguably the worst
character in the entire harry potter
story and she first makes her mark when
she infiltrates hogwarts and makes life
at the school a living hell probably an
understatement
that is until she's tricked into
traveling to the forbidden forest by
harry and hermione only to be met with a
horde of angry centaurs who carry her
off after this she's saved by dumbledore
and sacked from her headmistress
position after it's revealed that
voldemort had in fact returned amazingly
however umbridge still found herself
with a job after leaving hogwarts in
fact the ministry accepted her back in
her previous role of senior under
secretary to the minister of magic also
at this stage the ministry had a new
minister rufus skringer
despite a brief appearance at
dumbledore's funeral the next we hear of
umbridge is in 1997 following
voldemort's takeover of the ministry in
addition to her primary position of
under secretary umbridge also became
head of the muggleborn registration
commission where she conducted trials
that were effectively designed to
prosecute muggleborns umbridge doesn't
appear much more in the story after this
as there are bigger problems in the
wizarding world lord voldemort however
with voldemort's eventual downfall the
ministry once again came under the
control of normal witches and wizards
expunging all of voldemort's followers
from positions of power the ministry of
magic essentially underwent a
reformation led by a new minister for
magic fully aware of the type of person
that umbridge was and the crimes she had
committed during voldemort's regime the
new minister had umbridge rested tried
convicted and given a life sentence to
the island fortress of azkaban where she
lived out her days
2. cornelius fudge cornelius fudge order
of merlin first class self-appointed was
the 32nd minister for magic serving from
1990 to 1996 spanning most of the years
harry attended hogwarts fudge exhibited
some very questionable behavior during
his time in office the most questionable
being his persistent denial of
voldemort's return
which in turn caused fudge to meddle in
all kinds of affairs in the wizarding
world including the management of
hogwarts school when it was eventually
proven that voldemort had in fact
returned it cost fudge his job and rufus
scrimga took over his position
at this stage however fudge wasn't out
of the ministry entirely as he was kept
on in an advisory capacity communicating
news of the second wizarding war to the
mughal prime minister if scrimgar was
unable to when the war eventually ended
fudge was relieved of this position as
well
fudge's fate is exactly what can be
expected
when a foolish and ineffectual person is
given too much power
in the end fudge was scorned by the
public and unemployed quietly living the
rest of his shameful existence out of
the spotlight
take the steps i've suggested and you
will be remembered in office or out as
one of the bravest and greatest
ministers for magic we have ever known
fail to act and history will remember
you as the man who stepped aside and
allowed voldemort a second chance to
destroy the world we have tried to
rebuild albus dumbledore 3. lockhart in
the chamber of secrets lockhart is
forced by the boys to come down into the
chamber with them and this is where
things really went south for him hoping
to take control of the situation
lockhart grabbed ron's broken wand and
attempted to perform a memory charm on
them the adventure ends here boys i
shall take a bit of this skin back up to
the school tell them i was too late to
save the girl and that you two
tragically lost your mind at the sight
of her mangled body
say goodbye to your memories obliviate
however given that the wand was well
broken it backfired on lockhart instead
the faulty wand sent him flying into a
pile of rubble and subsequently caused
him to lose all of his memories complete
amnesia he was no longer the brave troll
conqueror and dragon tamer in fact he
didn't know who he was lockhart is later
saved by forks and brought to
mcgonagall's office at which point it
became apparent to staff and students
alike that lockhart had completely lost
his marbles with dumbledore instructing
ron to take him to the hospital wing
after careful inspection it was decided
that lockhart wouldn't be able to
operate in society in the state that he
was in and he was subsequently sent to
the jainus thickey ward in st mungo's
hospital for magical maladies a war
dedicated to those suffering from
permanent spell damage during christmas
in 1995 harry ron hermione and ginny saw
lockhart in the jainus thicky ward and
despite the total loss of his memory he
seemed just as lockhart as ever offering
up autographs and the like he'd regained
just enough memory to remember writing
in cursive teach me did i taught you
everything you know i expect did i well
how about those autographs then shall we
say a round dozen you can give them to
your little friends then and nobody will
be left out
sadly lockhart never got many visitors
but he still got fan mail from a witch
named gladys gudjin and developed a
close relationship with his carer miriam
strout
though lockhart never made a full
recovery he did sign autographs for the
rest of his days and it has been
expressed that he was happier that way
blissfully ignorant but more than happy
to reap the benefits of his illustrious
fame to this day no one knows if he ever
properly left saint mungo's 4. phillius
flitwick flitwick hogwarts resident
charms expert and dueling champion was
largely responsible for casting many of
the most effective defensive
enchantments surrounding hogwarts during
the great battle at the end of the
second wizarding war these defenses kept
the death eaters at bay for a
considerable amount of time and if it
weren't for his charms expertise then
the battle may have gone very
differently as it allowed the good guys
to get better prepared
flitwick is thought to be one of the
most talented charms teachers to ever
teach at hogwarts and following the
battle flitwick continued his tenure as
charms master diligently educating the
next generations of witches and wizards
on the topic
5. filch argus filch squibb went on to
assume the role of hogwarts caretaker
succeeding the previous caretaker
napoleon pringle in 1968. throughout the
books and films filch gives the trio
among many others their fair share of
grief but when the battle of hogwarts
came vilch was quick to oversee the safe
evacuation of most of the school
students he may have been foul tempered
and bitter but filch took his job
seriously which is why you won't be
surprised to hear that he continued on
in his position of caretaker after the
war had ended
immediately after the battle vilch was
seen sweeping near the great hall vilch
is likely still punishing students and
arguing with peeves to this day
6. ollivander ollivander first named
garrick operated olivender's one shop in
diagon alley one of harry's first stops
before beginning his first year at
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry
ollivander revolutionized the way that
one making was approached and before he
took over his father's one shop it was
common for wizards to use a broad
variety of wonder cores during the
second wizarding war ollivander was
tortured perhaps more than anyone else
this is due to ollivander's knowledge of
ones and voldemort's obsession with the
elder wand after recovering at shell
cottage for some time ollivander
traveled to muriel's house where he
remained until the end of the war
fortunately olivander ended up making a
full recovery and returned to work at
his one shop shortly after voldemort had
been defeated serving future witches and
wizards for decades to come 7. kingsley
shacklebolt kingsley shacklebolt was a
british pureblood wizard order of the
phoenix member powerful aura and later
minister for magic kingsley was a later
addition to the order and joined during
the second wizarding war kingsley was an
immense help against voldemort and the
death eaters during the wizarding war
and after helping to oversee the capture
and containment of death eaters and
voldemort supporters after voldemort's
defeat when the dust had finally settled
he was properly appointed as the 35th
official minister for magic he was
previously just caretaker minister
in this role among other acts kingsley
helped to rid the ministry of corruption
banned dementors from guarding azkaban
appointed harry as head of the aura
department and along with hermione
eradicated pro-pureblood views 8. pomona
sprout pomona sprout was a british witch
that taught at hogwarts for many years
she served as both the head of
hufflepuff house as well as the head of
the herbology department pomona proved
to be instrumental in helping the good
guys fight off the death eaters during
the battle of hogwarts tentacular devil
snare and snuggle off pods yes i'd like
to see the death eaters fighting those
after the war sprout remained teaching
at hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry as herbology professor and when
2008 rolled around she was joined in the
department by former pupil neville
longbottom who taught alongside her
9. arthur molly weasley let's start with
molly molly tarot actions during the
second wizarding war earned her quite
the reputation and she became quite well
known as the witch that defeated and
killed the notorious death eater
bellatrix lestrange arthur continued
working with the ministry of magic and
fought to improve muggle rights with the
help of kingsley shacklebolt other than
that molly and arthur lived out the rest
of their days quietly enjoying the
company of their dozen grandchildren 10.
percy weasley though percy had drawn
down a rather dubious path for most of
the books and films he did eventually
make up with his family during the
battle of hogwarts percy survived a
battle but like the rest of his family
was significantly affected by the death
of his brother fred
after the war percy returned to work for
the ministry as a high-ranking official
under the new minister for magic
kingsley shacklebolt he married a woman
named audrey and had two daughters molly
and lucy molly was of course named after
his mother and that's it for this video
if you want to check out 10 more
characters check out part 1 which i'll
link in the pinned comment as always if
you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live